federal court they have prosecuted
hundreds of terrorism cases since nine
eleven whereas you look at the military
commissions and they really only
prosecuted six cases
hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV and I'm
joined today by Human Rights Watch's
counterterrorism advisor Laura pitter
Laura thanks for joining us we're here
today to talk about a provision of a
bill that's going very much under the
radar screen in Washington DC having to
do with the way the United States
conducts the war on terror tell us what
is going on there are provisions in the
National Defense Authorization Act the
NDAA that relate to detention in the war
on terror and the provisions really are
the first time since the McCarthy era
that the Congress is authorizing the
detention of really anyone that the US
deems is an enemy the indefinite
detention of these people without trial
and without really a way to challenge
their detention by these people you mean
it could be someone on the battlefield
in Iraq it could be someone who's on
their farm in Iowa who are these people
well the terms in the bill are so vague
that it really can apply to anyone that
the US deems is an enemy so anyone who
is detained during these provisions then
are detained in military detention and
there's just very few procedures that
they can access to challenge that
detention and it applies to US citizens
as well now this is military detention
as opposed to the civil or the criminal
justice system here what's the
difference there what impact would that
have on the way that we currently
prosecute terrorism cases well there's a
provision in the act that mandates
military detention which means that it's
no longer going to be an option for the
federal system the Department of Justice
the FBI and local law enforcement to
take control of a certain category of
terrorism suspects it will be mandatory
military detention and the military will
then have control of deciding what
happens to these people so far the
military is a very poor record of
prosecuting these terrorism cases in
federal court they have prosecuted
hundreds of terrorism cases since nine
eleven whereas you look at the military
commissions and they really only
prosecuted six
faces so six against hundreds and we're
removing the ability to use that system
now by this new bill it mandates
military detention so yes the the
federal you know Department of Justice
the FBI all these entities that have
been very effective in fighting terror
and actually keeping America safe would
be cut out of the process and that would
be a permanent part of US law so it
would apply for this administration and
future administration's who's pushing
this well Congress are the ones that are
pushing it so it's passed the House well
one version passed the House and then it
has gone through subcommittee in the
Senate so it's now headed to the Senate
floor for a vote and there's virtually
been no discussion about it it was it
was the provisions were discussed and
passed in the senate armed services
committee so in a private closed session
and the chances of it being then signed
into law a match would be great because
it's part of a defense authorization and
no one is going to be against a defense
authorization exactly these the
provisions are they contain more powers
and normally war powers are something
that's discussed publicly but these
provisions are buried deep in a 600-page
National Defense Authorization Act so
they're not getting the public attention
that they deserve what does the Obama
administration and the Pentagon say
about this well similar provisions were
were proposed in the house and the White
House came out with a veto threat for a
lot of the provisions that would
interfere with the executives ability to
to transfer these cases into the federal
system and so now it's in the front of
the Senate and probably you know we
don't know what the administration's
position are is on the Senate provisions
at this point and for those of us who
care about quaint notions like habeas
corpus and and basic rights of Americans
to face a trial by their peers what does
this enshrine into law and what does
that say about where we are right now
well it's going to make it I mean
already provisions are virtually it's
virtually impossible to challenge your
military detention at this point the
only available means is habeas which is
normally a last resort
but it's so it's going to put more
people in that system and make it
there's going to be no procedures other
than a habeas challenge to challenge
your detention so we've passed the
Senate committee it's going to go up to
a floor vote when is the time frame on
this stuff so it has passed the Senate
subcommittee it's going to the Senate
floor for a vote after sometime after
recess we're not exactly sure when it
will come up but it it is going to come
up soon well all very ominous thank you
very much for joining us for reason TV
I'm Matt Welch